all right E4
oh another Carol Khan okay different
opponent though
this is one of the main lines
there's Knight D7
oh no my queen
I was running mate
the idea of this is the queen on E2
supporting the bishop
D4
that's a nice Harmony for white
not sure if I want a castle
[Music]
Bishop F4 first
I think B5 was was like a more of a main
line
instead of Bishop D6
okay so log wants to play C5
Bishop G3
ensuring the bishop is defended maybe
enabling
four move
so I'm trying to manage my time mother
that's one thing I've
I need to improve on based on these
games
Bishop H4
Bishop H4 is interesting
allows Knight F4
I
go insane
play this
and then
what to do
I feel like I've I've messed up a little
bit Queenie one
if Queen E2 there's another four
okay let's keep Queens on the board I'll
put the pawn on F3
let's just start with this so
and the G2 Pawn could come under Fire
but F3 should still
be okay
the E6 is a bit tender
good move
it's actually a very nice move
uh what to do
it should be two and be sad
if plunder the pawn to
extra sad now
that was such a bad move I should have
probably just taken
ah
this move
okay let me try and fight at least
this is kind of what I want Even though
this is not at all what I want
wait let's play Bishop F2 first
there's an obstacle or Bishop situation
so if I'm going to come back like
there's at least some chances for
counter play
C5 is a bit tender C4 though
hey
let's play this move
okay B4 is a bit tender now
I take
uh the lines don't work
if I Bishop D3 I have Rook B3
I might see some miracle
hopefully taken Bishop D4
I don't have that
okay Pawn should be lost that's not lost
ah this Pawn's lost
hmm
not even threading anything I'm
threatening one check
okay now I might have ideas
very tricky ideas
don't hurt me
oh wow fancy
what just happened
oh
by King
wow nice move
oh under promotes a knight
wow kudos to my opponent I'm not even
that upset
I got knifed
that was a great move
what a game
La Black's completely winning is is
promote tonight the only winning move
because otherwise I'm I'm doing things
wow okay Rook E3 also I guess works
but promote tonight wow
what a finish